[Music]
my next guest tonight is the co-creator
of the wildly popular online character
Marcel the show with shoes on which has
been viewed over 20 million times
her book Marcel the shell with shoes on
things about me is now a New York Times
bestseller here's a look at Marcel yes
what I wear is a hat lentil one time I
nibbled on a piece of cheese and my
cholesterol went up to 900 guess what I
used to tie my skis to my car the hair
guess what my skis are toenails from the
man thanks so much for being here first
of all you know I've worked in voiceover
before for years years going to work on
The Simpsons and and then when I heard
your voice for the first time I thought
how did this woman come up with this
voice it's fantastic the Marcel voice
thank you that's what I thought too yeah
if I'd known that I could do it before I
would have done it but I just like it
just came out and then I just couldn't
stop so you're in your apartment and
your walk around going I mean I can't do
it but it sort of comes it's sort of
just like it's like right here it's so
borderline creepy and then how did you
decide so you have the voice and you're
doing it how did you decide that the
voice is the voice of a shell oh yeah
that's a beautiful question um thank you
graduations gonna
thank you very much no please please
well I I think that the character of
Marcel is really beautiful and I have
always thought that shells are like the
jewels of the sea and the sea makes
shells for animals that look like like
basically like boogers you know right
but the sea makes them for them to live
in and it's sort of an honor and I don't
know at all it all just seemed like
that's what he should it does seem to
fit like you see the voice you see the
show they seem to come together did you
do voices as a kid did you grow up
because people who are good at voices
usually do them as children yeah I've
always done them and thank God I have a
job where I'm allowed to do them you
know otherwise I probably like be in
jail like a mental hospital but yeah I
my whole family has weird crazy voices
I'm from Boston and one whew me too okay
yeah I don't why I let that person who
and I said nothing Boston ain't never
heard of it yeah
well one of my grandmother's I've always
loved her voice and loved to mimic it
she was born in Cuba but her father was
Turkish and her mother was Russian and
she grew up in France well oh I know
that's craziness it's really weird and
her voice is kind of really it sounds
like a she sounds like a baby from like
an Asian country like somewhere like a
nonspecific Asian baby like when I told
her that I was coming on TV to do your
show she was like oh Jenny was so happy
for you and we can wait what you see on
the television TV and then you come back
sound and save you could use that what's
that voice gonna be were you gonna put
that on a shallow my gosh well there is
actually one shell in Marcel's world
that is based off my other grandmother
Nana Connie and her voice is like you
are so smart and you're gorgeous but
you're good and that's the most
important prize like no tone you know I
picture also a cigarette for some reason
but no no cigarettes
of hairspray okay that I can relate to